l'appel d'offres a été publié ce lundi
on y apprend que québec souhaite doter
chaque chambre des maisons des aînés
d'une caméra de surveillance
celle-ci se reposer face au lit au
plafond la chambre avec la possibilité
de pivoter sur 360 degrés ainsi sera
possible d'effectuer une tournée
visuelle des chambres à partir d'une
tablette qui vont faire ça va prendre du
monde pour surveiller les écrans pour
voir ce qui se passe le conseil pour la
protection des malades s'interroge sur
la pertinence de cette mesure dans un
contexte de pénurie travailleurs
rappelons-nous le drame qui est survenu
lors du décès de la mère de gilles
duceppe on avait vu après coup la dame
passé dans les écrans des usagers
rencontrés à moriat nord à l'heure du
midi ne cachent pas leur malaise face à
l'appel d'offres de québec c'est la vie
privée le seuil de sa porte elle a
respecté la vie bruit des gens non non
non non non non mais je trouve que c'est
un peu gênant
le ministre de la santé et christian
soubie est cependant convaincue de
l'incertitude de son gouvernement
je comprends pas comment on peut
d'office mettre des caméras comme dans
big brother sans s'y opposer
formellement certains chefs de partis de
l'efficacité de cette mesure c'est un
peu triste qu'on en soit rendu là et ça
peut pas être cela la solution pour
mieux prendre soin des aînés qui sont
hébergés rch à celle des siens concentre
9,7 façon libre et volontaire j'ai
aucune objection le ministère de la
santé précise toutefois que les caméras
ne seront pas activée en tout temps
seulement s'il est né le veut donc
l'année qui en veut pas de cameron en
chambre il y en aura pas dans sa chambre
l'association des sièges celle des
privés non conventionnés voit pour sa
part d'un bon oeil l'installation de
caméras steve mandanda 6 n'a quand même
pas besoin physiquement enfin le taux de
30 mille quarante mille pieds carrés de
superficie pour faire sa tournée visuel
des résidents mais on peut le faire en
sachant dans 35 ans ça change la donne
li maison des aînés ou coût d'environ
deux points 8 milliards de dollars
devrait permet d'héberger à terme près
de 3500 personnage est ici a dit yassine
radio canada montréal